سنبدا معك جيفارا هذه التصريحات حول
احتمال نشوب حرب في الجبهه الشماليه من
المسؤولين العسكريين الاسرائيليين تتكرر
ما جديتها جيفارا وماذا
وراءها هذه المره تصدر من اعلى هيئه
قياديه عسكريه في الصف الاول السي هرسي
هاليفي هو رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وادلى بهذه التصريحات خلال
تفقده لمناوره عسكريه ير يجريها الجيش
الاسرائيلي اي بعض الالويه في منطقه
الشمال شمالي اسرائيل هو يعتقد ان احتمال
نشوب الحرب مع لبنان قد تاتي وخلال الاشهر
القليله القادمه راميا ما يحدث من امكانيه
لنشوب هذه الحرب بان الجيش الاسرائيلي اخذ
الكثير من العبر خلال الحرب على غزه
وبالتالي الجيش قد يكون مستعد لهذه ايه
الحرب واان ما حدث في غزه ساعد الجيش
الاسرائيلي على تعزيز قدراته والثقه بذاته
حسب وصفه ولكنه ايضا قال ان الان تبقى هي
الحاله الدفاعيه للافراد واضح ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وان كان يلوح بهذه الحرب لكن
هناك نقطتين هامتين الاولى ان الجيش يربط
ايه او على الاقل رئيس هيئه الاركان يربط
ما حدث في قطاع غزه والحرب البريه بما
يمكن ان يحدث في داخل لبنان الامر الاخر
هو يؤكد ان الجيش الاسرائيلي على ك على
عكس كل التصريحات السابقه هو غير مؤهل
فعليا لخوض هذه الحرب ولكنه يقول بعد عده
اشهر اي ان عندما كان الحديث في بدايه
الحرب على غزه ان اسرائيل مستعده لخوض
حروب على عده جبهات لم يكن بذلك الطلاقه
بان الجيش على شكل افراد غير مستعدين يبقى
ذلك في اطار واضح انه التلويح
والتهديد ولكن على الارض هو يعرف وكان قد
تحدث اكثر من مره بان قوه حزب الله على
الاقل هي 10 اضعاف قوه حركه حماس وكتائب
عز الدين القسام في قطاع غزه وبالتالي هو
يدرك ان الدخول في المعركه البريه في داخل
لبنان ستكون اصعب عشر مرات من ما يحصده
الان من خسائر في داخل العمليه البريه
والحرب في قطاع غزه ايضا على المستوى
الميداني لازالت المعارك تتواصل بمعنى ال
الضربات الاسرائيليه تحولت من مستوى الى
اخر بمعنى من الرد الى رد الفعل الان الى
الهجوم بمعنى ان الان حزب اسرائيل هي من
تبادر عبر الجيش الاسرائيلي بقصف عده
مواقع اخرها كان مساء هذا اليوم وخلال
ساعات النهار دوت سافرات الانذار على
الاقل ست مرات فيم اكثر من 20 موقعا على
طول خط الحدود وحسب التقديرات الاسرائيليه
لهذا اليوم على الاقل اطلق خمس صواريخ
مضاده للدروع واكثر من 40 قذيفه
وصاروخ من داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه اتجاه
البلدات في الشريط الحدودي وداخل منطقه
الجليل الاعلى